à beyrouth qui a coûté la vie à 150
personnes après la visite des manuels
macro il a indiqué qu'il n'y aurait pas
quant à la souveraineté du liban de
michel aoun qui refusent l'idée d'une
enquête internationale
l'inde a franchi le cap des 2 millions
qui a déclaré de coronavirus le géant
d'asie du sud devient le troisième pays
à franchir ce seuil après les états unis
et brésil
il le pays qui compte plus d'un milliard
d'habitants comptabilise
2 et 41 mille morts du colis de 19 aces
tictoc kiwi chat toujours dans le viseur
de donald trump
les applications sont accusés
d'espionnage le président américain a
signé un décret pour interdire toute
transaction avec ses applications
mobiles chinoise la chine dénonce une
répression politique
tik tok menace de porter l affaire
devant les tribunaux des sanctions à
l'encontre de onze dirigeants pour gays
ont été annoncés
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue fils et 20
heures trois jours après la double
explosion qui a frappé beyrouth et qui a
coûté la vie à cent cinquante personnes
michel lalande le président libanais
elle n'écarte pas l'hypothèse d'un
éventuel missile ou d'une bombe
après la visite des manuels macron
acclamé par les libanais et michel aron
a indiqué qu'il n'y aurait pas d'
atteinte à la souveraineté sous son
mandat
en attendant la justice libanaise a
annoncé l'arrestation de 21
fonctionnaires du port de beyrouth et
des autorités douanières
le comité d'investigation doit rendre
ses conclusions à dans les prochains
jours avec les firmes de la ml
il est possible que cela ait été causé
par la négligence dans l'exécution des
procédures nécessaires pour qu'on n'en
soit pas arrivé là il m'a dit cela en
une telle icône un chinois he
il est possible que cela a été causé par
la négligence ou par une action
extérieure avec un missile ou une bombe
anadarko j'aime et je les aide
nous sommes confrontés à une révision de
notre système basé sur le consensus
car il est paralysé ne permet pas de
prendre des décisions qui peuvent être
mises en oeuvre rapidement
elles doivent être consensuel est passé
par plusieurs autorités sont en cours
pour cueillir elle son côté la
secrétaire générale gespunsart nasrallah
a déclaré dans une allocution télévisée
que son parti n'avait aucun lien avec
l'explosion
il répond aux accusations et aux rumeurs
dans les médias et au sein de l'opinion
publique
je voudrais annoncer et affirmé que je
nie totalement catégoriquement à ce
qu'il y ait quoi que ce soit à l'aise
dans le port nouma fesci
l'allemand paul martens la fille marine
cela nous n'avons rien dont le corps
ni entrepôts d'armes ni entrepôts de
missiles nine armes ni une bombe une
balle nitrate d'ammonium il n'y a
absolument rien de tout cela
ni entre quo ni rien d'autre âme ni dans
le présent ni dans l'eau passait rien du
tout il n'y a rien de tout cela
volontaire et secouristes étrangers
s'activent à beyrouth pour tenter de
retrouver les disparus sous les
décombres on dénombre déjà plus de 5000
blessés et des dizaines de disparus
les précisions de l'uqat choix aux
abords du port de beyrouth le chaos et
le silence succède au vacarme des
explosions de mardi dernier
ce vendredi quatre corps ont été sortis
des décombres les disparus se comptent
encore par dizaines mon cousin et sa
femme ont disparu mon cousin s'appelle i
mazza ed din
il travaille en tant que gardien au port
il a disparu depuis l'explosion
mon frère ibrahim ali amin travail dans
les silos de céréales nous ne l'avons
plus revu depuis trois jours pour
fouiller les décombres
l'aide est internationale l'union
européenne a débloqué 33 millions
d'euros en urgence
washington plus de 12 millions d'euros
paris envoie des avions et des équipes
de secouristes de médecins des efforts
coordonnés avec ses voisins allemands et
italiens des aides de l'iran des émirats
arabes unis et de l'arabie saoudite
arrive aussi à beyrouth
rome a déjà livré plus de huit tonnes
d'aidé médicale tandis que la russie
montrent un hôpital mobile pour
désengorger ceux de la capitale
au cours de la journée de travail d'hier
nous avons malheureusement retirés des
décombres trois corps de personnes
décédées
aujourd'hui nous avons repris le travail
à 5 heures du matin l'accueil des
patients l'hôpital mobile se poursuit
vous voyez l'hôpital fonctionne de 8h à
21h
aujourd'hui 20 à 25 personnes attendent
un traitement en mode ambulatoire
alors on a deux zones de recherche
principal celle ci était la première
étant donné la proximité par rapport au
lieu de l'explosion
on s'est créé des personnes qui
travaillent sur zone ça nous a donné
raison puisque on a trouvé des personnes
il ya une deuxième zone en centre ville
directement
la paire la zone la plus touchée de la
ville par rapport explosif dans le
centre ville justement la mobilisation
est aussi citoyenne de nombreux libanais
s'organisent pour déblayer et nettoyer
les rues et pour porter assistance à
ceux qui en ont besoin
il n'y a rien à dire la seule chose à
faire est que chacun essaye d'aider là
où il le peut c'est peut-être la seule
petite chose que les gens peuvent faire
descendre et nettoyer les rues aider à
ramasser le verre brisé
déblayer les décombres quoi que ce soit
tant que nous aidons les uns les autres
et que nous sommes solidaires nous
sommes en train d'envoyer des gens dans
les maisons endommagées des personnes
âgées des personnes handicapées pour les
aider à trouver un logement pour ce soir
et nous essayons de les aider à nettoyer
leurs maisons afin qu'elle puisse
retourner y vivre
beyrouth doit maintenant renaître de ses
cendres
en parallèle du travail des secours une
enquête a été ouverte par la justice
libanaise pour déterminer les
responsabilités dans cette tragédie
pour patrick baz chirurgien l'hôtel-dieu
de france à beyrouth ce drame aggrave la
situation du pays et coûté le depuis
octobre nous vivons une crise économique
très dur qui va en s'aggravant
en plus le colonat virus vient aggraver
les choses parce qu'il a bloqué le pays
pendant deux mois
et maintenant nous avons se lit sur le
gâteau cette explosion qui a endommagé
beyrouth
donc même les gens qui s'en sortait plus
ou moins ne peuvent plus s'en sortir ils
ont perdu déjà leur emploi ou une partie
de leur salaire
beaucoup d'entreprises ont fermé et
maintenant ils perdent leur maison leur
santé et leur vie donc on est au fond du
gouffre est passé à la situation
dramatique au liban washington annonce
envoyé un peu plus de 12 millions
d'euros de nourriture et de médicaments
une offre pourtant contraire à la loi
césar instauré depuis le mois de juin
par les américains souvenez-vous ce
projet avait pour but de sanctionner la
syrie et ses partenaires commerciaux
notamment le pays du cèdre est les
détails avec roman tu elle les états
unis entre sanction et secours à l'égard
du liban quelques heures après la double
explosion qui a frappé beyrouth ce mardi
les promesses des de la communauté
internationale se multiplient rapidement
la france et la russie offre un soutien
humain et matériel pour aider aux
opérations de secours
d'autres états et institutions annoncent
une mobilisation en faveur des libanais
parmi ces propositions celle du
gouvernement américain nous sommes prêts
à porter assistance au gouvernement du
liban alors qu'il fait face à cette
horrible tragédie
vous verrez les états unis annoncé une
série de mesures que nous comptons
adopter pour aider le peuple libanais
ces prochains jours une offre
d'assistance surprenante quelques
semaines seulement après la mise en
application de la loi césar le 17 juin
dernier
ce texte autorise des sanctions
supplémentaires et des restrictions
financières à l'encontre des
institutions et des individus qui
réalisent des échanges commerciaux avec
la syrie
initialement dirigées contre damas cet
arsenal législatif a également touché
d'autres pays de la région comme le
liban voisin en effet dès l'annoncé de
son entrée en vigueur la livre libanaise
a connu une importante dévaluation un
effondrement de la monnaie nationale qui
plonge un peu plus le pays dans la crise
une pression américaine dea
non c'est par hassan nasrallah
secrétaire général du hezbollah
des informations confirmées indiquent
que les états unis interdisent la
livraison de dollars au liban en
quantité suffisante sous prétexte que le
hezbollah achètent des dollars pour les
transférer en syrie ou en iran la loi
césar vise à affamer le liban comme elle
vise à affamer la syrie entre marasme
économique situation sanitaire
incertaine et catastrophe humanitaire
le liban traverse l'une des pires crises
de son histoire des conditions de vie
qui pourrait s'aggraver davantage en
raison de la politique d' asphyxie menée
par l'administration de donald trump et
pour maxime shaikh père journaliste et
fondateur de deep news media il faut
d'abord penser à venir en aide aux
milliers de familles libanaises dans la
détresse et qu elle
moi j'aimerais recentrer le débat sur la
population sur les populations du levant
qui ont subi depuis neuf ans une guerre
absolument atroce avec des centaines de
milliers de morts et le liban accueilli
notamment entre 1 et 1 million et demi
de réfugiés sur une population de 5
millions et demi d'habitants
mais quand on parle de punir des pays
ont puni les populations avant tout
parce que les élites politiques
elles ont des ressources financières
allant des alliés sont dans des systèmes
financiers complexes qui leur permettent
d'échapper à ces sanctions
moi je pense à la population libanaise à
la population syrienne et ça représente
des millions de personnes qui subissent
aujourd'hui par un cataclysme économique
avec un effondrement du niveau 2 me de
du niveau de vie pardon un
renchérissement des denrées alimentaires
des biens de première nécessité et une
crise économique sans fin qui engendre
des pénuries d'énergie qui engendre un
manque cruel d'opportunités d'emploi et
d'avenir
plus de soixante mille personnes ont
signé une pétition pour placer le liban
sous mandat français pour les dix
prochaines années
dans ce texte mis en ligne après la
double explosion qui a touché entre
elles les auteurs anonymes dénonce
l'incapacité des autorités libanaises à
sécuriser et à gérer le pays
il critique un système défaillant la
corruption le terrorisme
nice selon eux sous mandat français le
liban a bénéficierait d'une seconde
chance en france à présent au la hausse
du nombre de nouveaux cas d'infection au
corona virus inquiète
en quelques jours le nombre de personnes
identifiées positive a connu une hausse
de plus de 30% ces dernières 24 heures
plus de 1600 cas où ont été recensés
plusieurs grandes villes impose
désormais le port du masque dans
certaines zones en extérieur
conséquence hier emmanuel macron a
annoncé la tenue la semaine prochaine
d'un conseil de défense sur le colis de
et pour françois cravans qui médecin
spécialiste en santé publique
le mot d'ordre est simple cet été double
vigilance mayenne double vigilance
certains la vigilance pour la reprise du
corona virus est là les fortes chaleurs
pour qu'ils arrivent pour les personnes
fragiles alors les personnes fragiles
notamment les personnes âgées qui sont
donc à la fois à risque mortel à cause
du virus et à risque de dégradation
alors il faut évidemment être vigilant
sur tous les tableaux
il faut que tout le monde fasse très
attention respecte les gestes barrières
et pas dans le match qu'un le must de la
sortie des rangs la rappeler les gestes
barrière ils sont efficaces ils sont où
ceux appliqués le match en fait partie
mais il faut tous les respecter au
maximum
et aussi on le répète à chaque canicule
être très vigilant prendre des nouvelles
des personnes âgées s'hydrater éviter
les sorties au soleil trop longue les
héros il fait plus chaud et à l'ombre
pour les enfants pour les personnes
âgées et les personnes fragiles donc
double vigilance en cette période qui
montre à quel point la santé publique et
le respect et le finalement l'autonomie
de chacun reste dans le monde également
plusieurs pays sont en alerte le royaume
uni ou encore l'espagne redoutent
l'arrivée d'une deuxième vague
épidémique de nouvelles mesures sont des
mais appliquée sur le vieux continent le
point en images regarder
où
[Musique]
la pandémie de couronnes à virus
continue de faire des ravages notamment
en inde qui est devenu le troisième pays
à franchir le seuil des deux millions de
cas le géant d'asie du sud qui compte
1,3 milliard d'habitants a enregistré
plus de 41000 mort du collier de 19
l'accès au dépistage rasteau limiter les
experts estiment que ces chiffres
pourraient être sous-évalué
jordi d'amaury 2 millions de personnes
infectées c'est le seuil franchi ce
vendredi en inde seulement trois
semaines après avoir officiellement
déclaré un million de cas avec 1,3
milliard d'habitants le géant d'asie du
sud devient le troisième pays au monde à
atteindre ce chiffre après les états
unis et le brésil
les autorités indiennes ont testé
environ seize mille cinq cents personnes
par million d'habitants contre 190
milles aux états unis des études
sérologique récentes suggèrent que le
nombre réel de cas serait bien plus
élevé que celui présenté dans le bilan
officiel est qu'une grande partie
d'entre eux seraient asymptomatiques
si tous les organismes gouvernementaux
avaient été en alerte dès que cela a
commencé notre pays seraient exempts du
coronavirus aujourd'hui le gouvernement
a fait preuve de faiblesse à cet égard
les discriminations qui vise les
personnes atteintes du coc vie 19
peuvent aussi dissuader certains de se
faire dépister les autorités colle ainsi
des affiches sur la façade du domicile
des personnes testées positives pour
signaler la présence d'un malade
d'isolement c'est pour protéger les
autres et quand vous revenez de
l'isolément que vous avez accepté pour
protéger les autres
on considère que vous avez quelque chose
à vous reprocher si l'épidémie de
coronavirus avait pour principaux
épicentre les mégapoles de new delhi et
bombay la maladie touche désormais les
régions moins denses
il y as certainement une crainte du
coronavirus mais nous gardons distance
les uns par rapport aux autres
nous avons peu de liens avec les villes
nous faisons venir des produits du
marché voisin en fonction de nos besoins
le port généralisé du masque est
globalement respecté dans les villes il
l'est en revanche moins dans les zones
rurales où vivent deux indiens sur trois
sur le continent africain en dénombre
plus d'un million malade est parmi les
pays qui rapportent un nombre de cas
élevé pour un million d'habitants figure
l'afrique du sud malgré des chiffres
alarmants le continent n'est pas parmi
les plus atteints par le courant n'a et
russe et pour saya venu mon médecin un
chirurgien l afrique peut faire face à
cette pandémie ecoutez-le quand vous
prenez la route du sud le niveau de la
médecine
elle est très élevée quand on a l'argent
c'est pas tous pas toujours élevé pour
tout le monde c'est à dire les gens qui
n'ont pas suffisamment de moyens ne
peuvent pas se soigner correctement ils
sont aussi comme tout le reste de la
flûte ou connaît l'algérie le maroc ce
sont des endroits où il ya quand même un
minimum de niveau d'équipement et c'est
peut-être pour ça que c'est dans ces
pays aussi conteste contexte beaucoup
plus mais un calme depuis d'un char je
pense qu'ils sont en mesure de prendre
en charge parce que le plus de cas ne
veut pas dire le plus de cas
hospitalisés
et quand on réalise le nombre de cas
hospitalisés par rapport au nombre de
cas positifs
ce n'est pas très important encore une
fois la population africaine et les
treize jeunes à plus de quand on prend
l'afrique en général surtout
subsaharienne on a plus de 60 % de gens
qui osent à peine 30 ans complètement et
ceux de 65 ans ceux qui ont plus de 65
ans ne représentent que 2% de la
population alors que les 60 plus de 60%
de la population dans des pays européens
par exemple
donc il ya une forte prévalence une
forte population qui est positive mais
qui ne nécessitera pas une
hospitalisation
tik tok et witch est toujours dans le
viseur de donald trump évoquant une
urgence nationale le président américain
a signé hier un décret interdisant toute
transaction avec la maison mère
un décret qui prendra effet dans 45
jours pour buydens la maison mère
chinoise tik tok le président américain
elles les accusent d'espionner les
utilisateurs américains
tik tok a menacé d'engager des
poursuites judiciaires et pékin a
aussitôt réagi les entreprises
concernées exercent des activités
commerciales aux etats unis conformément
aux principes du marché et aux règles
internationales et respectent les lois
et réglementations américaines sous
prétexte de sécurité nationale les états
unis abuse fréquemment de leurs pouvoirs
étatiques et sévices de manière
injustifiée contre les entreprises non
américaines
il s'agit d'un acte d'intimidation
flagrant et la chine s'y oppose
fermement
nous avons également remarqué que
récemment de nombreuses personnes aux
états unis et des personnes de tous les
horizons de la communauté internationale
ont critiqué est remis en question
l'approché américaine depuis
conséquences peuvent avoir les menaces
de donald trump un élément de réponse
avec à fabrice epelboin enseignant à
sciences po et spécialiste des réseaux
sociaux sur tik tok pression une perte
de balle heures mais en même temps une
bonne potentiellement une affaire
juteuse avec microsoft sur 108 chatte
une déconfiture en bourse le cours de
bourse a plongé de 10% et probablement
une multitude de problématiques qui se
posent entre la diaspora chinoise et les
familles restées en chine parce que oui
chat est aujourd'hui et depuis longtemps
l'outil qui permet à toutes ces familles
de communiquer de rester unis donc là
dessus il ya toujours moyen de
contourner se sépare de censure mais ça
va obliger beaucoup de monde à
contourner des dispositifs de censure
washington continuent l'offensive contre
la chine des sanctions à l'encontre de
onze dirigeants ont congas dont la chef
de l'exécutif car il a moins été
annoncée ils sont accusés de chercher à
restreindre l'autonomie du territoire
ainsi que la liberté d'expression avec
la loi sur la sécurité nationale
un point imposé fin juin par pékin à
l'archipel
un avion de ligne s'est écrasé dans le
sud de l'inde l'impact
séparez la pareille en deux la police
évoque 14 morts et 15 blessés graves
l'avion transportait près de 200
personnes à bord et les sauvetages sont
en cours
l'appareil de la compagnie air india
express était en provenance de dubaï
ils auraient raté son atterrissage
d'urgence à l'aéroport de calais culte
dans la région du kerala à plus
d'informations dans nos prochaines
éditions
il en reste de l'actualité
internationale
en bref et en images un nouvel
affrontement entre les palestiniens les
forces de sécurité israéliennes près de
tueur moussaya au nord de jérusalem et
manifestants palestiniens protestent eux
contre les nouveaux projets de
colonisation israéliens les soldats
iraniens ont fait usage d'un canon à eau
de grenades lacrymogènes et de lanceurs
de balles en caoutchouc
cinq protestataires ont été blessés
selon le ministère palestinien de la
santé
une marée noire qui menace l'île maurice
il y a deux semaines un navire panaméen
s'est échoué sur un récif
hier la coque du bateau s'est fissuré
des hydrocarbures se sont déversés dans
l'écosystème selon les autorités
mauriciennes et les ong craignent un
désastre écologique en raison des 200
tonnes de diesel et 3800 tonnes de
pétroles lourds présents dans les cales
le gouvernement de l'île maurice s'est
tourné vers les autorités françaises
pour obtenir de l'aide
la justice belge rejette la demande
d'extradition de l'indépendantiste
catalan louis switch vers l'espagne elle
considère que l'autorité espagnole qui a
émis ce mandat n'était pas compétente
madrid accusent risque which de
détournement de fonds publics et de
désobéissance une victoire pour les
indépendantistes catalans qui pourraient
avoir une influence sur la demande
d'extradition espagnol visant leur
leader en exil caralp agent qui sous le
coup d'un mandat d'arrêt de la justice
espagnole pour sédition et détournement
de fonds
twitter a décidé de marquer d'un libellé
les comptes des médias affiliés à un
état et de réduire leur portée est ce le
cas pour tous les médias et bien la
réponse est non si rt ou cctv se voit
infliger cette notification d'autres
médias financiers par des états
étrangers comme france 24 où la bbc y
échappent
et c'est loin d'être la première fois
quelques tics off
et ça continue ah oui pas s'arrêter en
si bon chemin
vu que désormais ce sont les réseaux
sociaux qui décide de qui est
journaliste et qui ne l'est pas autant
continuer depuis le 6 août
twitter a décidé d'ajouter un petit
libellé sous les comptes de certains
médias pour je cite fournir aux
internautes davantage de contexte sur
ses comptes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en vérité pas
grand chose le but qu'on devine derrière
cet étiquetage et politique
désormais lorsque vous vous rendrez sur
le compte twitter de arte france vous
verrez ça
officiellement twitter se dédouane de
toute stigmatisation
à l'heure actuelle ils s'affichent sur
les comptes mais qu'à conserver des cinq
pays membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies chine etats
unis france royaume uni et russie
dans les faits c'est faux ni france24 ni
la bbc nil américaine npr national
public radio ne voient leur compte
porter de signes distinctifs seuls ceux
liés à la chine et la russie sont
concernés en gros les méchants du
conseil de sécurité
twitter évoque les comptes
gouvernementaux fortement engagé en
matière de géopolitique et de diplomatie
c'est sûr que la france ou le royaume
uni sont pas du tout engagé en matière
de géopolitique ou de diplomatie
je suis là aujourd'hui pour vous dire
d'abord la solidarité l'amitié du peuple
français et dont le peuple libanais je
ne négocierai aucun délai avec l'union
européenne
pas du tout contrairement aux médias
indépendants les médias liés à l'état
d'esprit qu'avant la couverture de
l'actualité à des fins politiques parce
que ce que fait twitter en stigmatisant
un média scénario politique
nous pensons que les gens ont le droit
de savoir quand le compte d'un média et
a filé directement ou indirectement un
acteur étatique
nous pensons que vous faites dans la
stigmatisation la plus primaire chez
twitter nous avons conscience que la
valise et décomptes des médias comme
étant affiliés à des gouvernements est
un travail difficile
il y en a tellement si certains médias
russes ont reçu cette étiquette d'autres
médias d'état ne bénéficient toujours
pas de ce privilège
voici donc quelques indices au plaisir
la bbc est le premier diffuseur celui
commandes et à vie par une charte royale
la bbc est principalement financé par le
droit de licence payée par les ménages
britanniques
votre rôle est de remplir votre mission
est de promouvoir nos objectifs publics
le radiodiffuseur public financé par des
ressources fiscales fédérales meilleure
fiche du bape est enregistrée auprès de
narnia metz en tant que société privée à
but non lucratif et est financé par une
subvention des congrès américain par
l'intermédiaire de l'agencé des états
unis pour les médias mondiaux en tant qu
a mérité cette fille pourquoi une telle
différence de traitement des médias
financés par les institutions étatiques
mais je me sens d'une indépendance
éditoriale est arrivé si elles ne seront
pas concernés ouais en gros vous fait la
pluie et le beau temps et vous réserver
le droit de décider qui jouit d'une
indépendance éditoriale ou non mais
c'est quoi les critères en fait ce que
je vois pas le ca twitter ne précise pas
il laisse le libre choix aux internautes
d'interpréter cette différence de
traitement comme une discrimination
politique c'est de la pure
discrimination c'est vous qui voyez
critères ne rendra pas les comptes des
entités médiatique acquise hier à
lesquin lille orléans
nous avons demandé à l'avocat du diable
de rtl regard demander ce qu'il en pense
quoi
c'est totalement discriminatoire et
d'illustrer merveille le parti pris des
réseaux sociaux américains
ces réseaux sociaux sont partis en
guerre idéologique contre ce qu'ils
considèrent comme étant le camp du mal
il leur sera désormais impossible de
continuer à revendiquer leur statut de
plateforme neutre
ils devront être traités comme des
éditeurs de contenus leur argument pour
qualifier les médias indépendants de
ceux qui ne le sont pas sont grotesques
pour quiconque s'intéresse un tant soit
peu aux médias en même temps j'ai envie
de dire la décision de twitter n'a rien
de surprenant vu les discriminations que
rt subit déjà en mai de l'année dernière
et youtube avait décidé de labelliser
les médias publics ou gouvernementaux
sous leurs vidéos mais avec une
différence sémantique notable rt
français selon au label de youtube
financé par le gouvernement russe qu'en
france 24 où la bbc sont des chaînes de
service public français et ou
britanniques
deux poids deux mesures et bien sûr le
fait que rt françois une chaîne
française composée de journalistes
français qui a signé une convention avec
le csa qui dispose d'une charte de
déontologie
deux syndicats de journalistes et d'un
comité d'éthique sa twitter s'en fout on
vit une époque formidable
et pour eric verhaegue fondateur du blog
le cours et des stratèges elle les
réseaux sociaux deviennent de plus en
plus engagés politiquement
on comprend aujourd'hui que les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus une vraie force
politique et que dans ce poids politique
qu'ont acquis définitivement les réseaux
sociaux dans le débat public
les réseaux sociaux sont en train de
s'organiser pour essayer de prendre de
juguler le formaliser de réguler leur
influence politique en essayant
d'établir des critères et on voit bien
que ces critères aujourd'hui faute
une délibération collégiale ils sont
faits au petit bonheur la chance et soul
influence politique notamment des pays
qui hébergent des réseaux donc on voit
bien que les états unis les pays
occidentaux tendent à imposer un certain
nombre de critères qui leur conviennent
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochaine édition dans 30
minutes rester avec nous sur arte france
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce